hello tanish
karnik you were the first one solomonel
thank you for the welcome back
i am doing good thank you all for asking
i'm still a little um hold on let me
is the audio good sounds like it
you were the first one solomon thank you
for the welcome back
okay everything seems good i'm feeling
all right
my legs are all wrapped up let me see if
i can show you
my legs are all messed up
so so yeah
um i'm feeling good though i'm
forgive me if i'm a little out of it
today
um just because i'm still on some pain
meds because the surgery was yesterday
let me turn this down
what are our final theories because i
think some stuff's about to go down
tonight i i really do i really think
some stuff's about to go down
let's see let's see
i really think some stuff's gonna go
down
and i wonder if we're gonna see the
engineer
i knew that we weren't gonna see it last
time like i just i just felt like
i just felt like i knew i wasn't going
to see it that time so
i think we're going to see this time hey
the legendary one what's up straight out
of surgery and into theories yep that's
pretty much how it is um
because this is what we do right i would
do this anyways right like
i would do this on my own this is what i
love i love marvel
i mean this is what we do
so i'm thinking
i'm thinking blue marvel is what they're
going for unfortunately
i there's nothing wrong with blue marvel
he's just not as hype as reed richards
right so i mean by the end of the stream
you'll have a thousand dollars for me oh
dang
well thank you ocsyncs
super appreciate that and as always i'm
going to try to get
every single possible uh
super chat that that i possibly can um
you want madame webb jc's channel thank
you so much
i am back you want madame webb yeah
who knows what they're going to be doing
what the uh with their spider-verse
and uh with spider-man
no way home which is like
which is like it's an okay title
i mean it's kind of what i expected
right it's it's
it's a very expected title um
and it's funny how in that whole reveal
they teased
the other titles because they totally
did a tease
of excuse me home worlds
and it's like i i said it was homeworld
that's what i wanted to be i should say
and i put it
in all of my like thumbnails and stuff
hey j showtime you the man thank you so
much
you're the man for that donation that's
super chat thank you really appreciate
that
um uh
lost my train of thought completely lost
my train of thought
i think he's been super chat though i
appreciate that um
what i was saying oh were you talking
about spider-man yeah i think they
totally
like that was the tease at us
like as a fandom where on the whiteboard
they wrote
they wrote um homeworld's boring and
it's like
come on it's not boring like
mario camo as nightmare or al pacino as
mephisto happy to see your back and
doing well thank you so much matt
matt hutch um thank you so much for that
super chat
yeah um that would be crazy cool mark
hamill or al pacino like can you imagine
albacino mcu
it'd be crazy rocky pandir thank you so
much
for that super chat uh it says message
redacted
so if you put a message i'm sorry i
don't see it
um oc zynx thank you so much for super
chat nightmare blue marvel
uh and blue marvel yeah i i think
i was talking about that in the
beginning of the of the chat
unfortunately i do
think i shouldn't say unfortunately
because there's nothing wrong with blue
marvel's character i
just he's not going to be as hype
and he's not going to get fans as
excited as reed richards or somebody
else would be
whiten yankin
ynk3n i'm so sorry if i can't pronounce
that incan
do you think we see have arkana jones
today
um yeah i think they showed her
they showed her briefly last episode um
and i think it's only i i think she has
a role like i do think she has a role
so is you know is she another powerful
witch with agatha
that goes back all the way to the salem
witch trials
let's see um sumac's o-ring bomb
i am good uh i look perfectly fine
but my legs are all
like this and i'm still
like on some pain pills so forgive me if
i'm a little drowsy today
but thank you for that super chat i i am
uh i'm good
uh there's another super chat i want to
make sure we get solomon l thank you so
much for super chat
aou mentions nexus as internet hub of
the world
yeah and um and i think that's a play on
this and i think
wanda is kind of the nexus of the
multiverse is kind of what i think is
going on here
did i miss one nightmare but no i didn't
miss one well we have
six minutes left six minutes left
what do we think happened to wanda's
kids does
does agatha have them and sacrifice and
sacrifice
them to whoever she's going to summon
lancaster swedish name by the way
awesome now
your english was fine i understood
perfectly it was your it was the name
that i was having
kind of a trouble wondering if i
pronounced the name right
but no your your angle seems fine
what time is it over there in sweden
i wonder what happens to the kids guys
the kids are trapped somewhere was that
lewis could strap some more
hey malek shepherd yeah i'm feeling kind
of better i mean again guys i'm sorry if
i'm lying a little out of it today
i am on some some pain pills still um
to get me through they basically cut
open my feet
um i've had problems walking like
forever um
since it was like a condition i was born
with so i've had problems
walking and over the past
five years it's got progressively worse
it's on and off
um but it's like a bone degenerative
disorder and a
like a nerve disorder so doctors said it
was time
to take some action and do surgery and
try to get them better
and let's hope it works let's hope it
works roxanne monique thank you so much
for that super chat
can't wait this is the longest four
minutes ever i know
there's always like the worst part uh
waiting for for
you know the shows to come out and i i
feel so bad for
for everyone who has the problem like
trying to get the
the show to play because that happens
every time i see it in the chat
that means like every time people people
like it's not on jesse plus it's not on
just plus it's not just a plus
james edwards thank you thank you for
that super chat i appreciate that
um and roxanne again thank you i
appreciate that what do we have now
what are we at now
three minutes man i
yes 12 a.m 12 a.m technically
pst um i
am feeling a little bit better thank you
for all who are
who are asking um
let me pull this up here so i don't miss
any of the super chats here so i don't
i want to be sure to not miss any
cool three minutes still
well i don't
think ah it's so hard to tell if one is
kids are going to come back or not i
like in my mind she's trapped them
and hey james edward thank you again for
that super chat
and wolf woof everybody's saying woof
uh what woof woof actually comes from
the white wolf which is the character
that bucky barnes plays in wakanda
um that's where that came from because i
couldn't pronounce or i could pronounce
but when i would say wolf
like the white wolf it would say woof
because i just talk fast and i say the
white wolf
so people kind of made fun of me for it
so i kind of embraced it
and i started saying woof woof so and
people liked it actually when i started
doing that
so i just kept doing it um i know a lot
of people have been asking like
where did woof woof come from and that's
that's kind of what it is and i just do
that for the people who
who are there from the beginning and the
people who are there now they they
really like it
so all right
about one minute
until our minds are possibly blowing
because you have to think they're not
gonna save
like they can't save everything for the
finale right they're gonna have to start
getting
pretty intense right now i mean they got
intense last time because wanda's kids
are gone i cannot open
my g fuel there we go
it got pretty intense last time just
wanted his kids are gone
and oh this chat's faster than this chat
hey the food blogger's kitchen what's up
man i appreciate that
appreciate that i enjoy our messages on
instagram
oh you had foot surgeon surgery recently
as well
danger diabolic i'm sorry
mispronounced that um yeah speedy
recovery to you too
and thank you both for the super chat
guys we have one minute
i'm getting mine ready so if you have
your disney plus out
have that ready um i will show
random clips and stuff of it i am back
home as you can tell now
um i am back home so
james edward thank you again for that
dollar
for that super chat super appreciate it
okay that's what i am
do we have it
one division is 47 minutes long no
that leak was right all right here we go
i'm gonna start this in three
two one
i've started it
well that's not good hold on
hold on i have to i have to do it again
my timer is not right it always does
this it like
logs me out why am i not signed in
what is happening
um all right let's try to watch it now
i'm playing it
um
i'm having problems problems playing it
guys
uh-oh this is not good let's do this
uh oh oh i missed the super chat i'm
sorry
i'm trying to play it but it's not
coming up
chris
uh i can't play it right now guys um
this is an issue
well i'm trying to play it but it isn't
letting me
dang it i think it's like i think it's
like crashing
because i can't play it right now
um
crap
i have to call my roommate
i can't play one division
you think that's what it is
dang it hasn't happened to me yet
you don't think it's because we're both
trying to be on the internet right now
huh
dang
all right
okay guys this is what's happening the
servers are kind of crashed right now
for me
i uh i'm trying to get it up
but it's not working right now because
too many people are trying to stream it
i'm trying to watch it on my phone i
won't let me but all right we'll figure
it out
too many people are trying to stream it
episode 8 is not streaming now because i
can't scream it it's totally crashed
oh some people are watching it well i'm
trying
let's hopefully hopefully it doesn't
take
you know much longer
i'm trying on like all my computers
on everything my computer my phone
my other computer i have three computers
i'm trying it on
well that just means that people are
getting really into one division
does it play old episodes
nope it's not even playing old episodes
yeah the server just can't handle it
i can't even watch it right now dang
i'm trying
i missed some serious mini sing thank
you so much for that
david bennett it happens to me every
week same message give it a minute oh
dang
happens to you every week this is the
first time that's happened to me i feel
so bad that it's happened to you every
week
dang i'm gonna keep trying i'm trying on
my laptop i'm trying on my other
computer i'm trying on my phone
dang and for those of you who are asking
yes i am getting on
with supes and brad and chris my
roommate and
co-host on cosmic culture
come on marvel
and chris apparently can't stream it
either oh wait
i think i got it i got it okay sweet
previously oh but i need this
both killed during an air raid when
maximoff and her twin brother pietro
were 10.
the twins were subsequently radicalized
volunteering
i can't show all this guys i'm sorry i
can't do it
but hey thank you for the super chats if
i missed any apologize
adam butler what up dude how's it going
man
the quarter of boy fresh breath is going
to work for me i have it now um
it's a recap right now i'll randomly
i'll randomly bring the screen up guys
but i can't uh i obviously can't show it
the whole entire time but i will
randomly bring the screen
back up is there an echo
all right cool here we go
i guess i don't need this all right
i'm gonna kind of show it every now and
then let's say
it's just the marvel studios logo right
now
and there we go
oh no way that's so cool already we got
which scenes already
which scenes salem massachusetts 1693
hey mumbo jazzy thank you thank you for
super chat
it's good to be back oh snap
the witches are taking agatha
guys there will i will talk about
spoilers here so you better you better
watch out
they're about to burn this girl at the
stake
oh snap
guys i am going to talk spoilers so if
you don't want spoilers
you guys should get up
oh she has oh oh she has the brooch
oh
this is intense oh snap
dang
oh
ho ho oh my gosh guys
this is insane
oh whoops what did i do
i got this going to town on all the
other oh snap
holy crap spoiler warning right now
agatha just killed a ton of witches
and she's fighting her mom
oh
wow what an opening scene
what an opening scene oh and there it is
frick
she's talking to the bunny now
[Music]
trying to read her mind
hahaha
oh whoa
that's what those are is
wow
wow this is getting crazy cool
fake phrase true
this is intense guys she's talking about
patreon she's talking about
how she created the fake pietro and she
called him fake troll
and she was she was watching wanda for a
while
she has that fly in her hand what is
this
she's transforming wow
she just transformed that into a bird
like a real witch like passing
like casting hexes and
oh poor not poor birdie
oh she's like straight up destroying
wanda right now
it's insane she's like i tried to be
gentle
oh she's about to show her
something
oh snap
oh she just plucked her one of her hairs
out
she's about to cast a crazy spell
now this door is opening oh snap
she's going to show her the past she's
going to show her past that she's been
repressing what was that
oh the kids are alive she can hear them
well it could be a trick
oh no they're there whoa oh that's her
oh they're gonna show her her past
wait where is this is this with vision
or is this in sokovia
agatha is showing wanda her past
oh it's her mom
and her dad
wow it's her mom and her dad she's
watching
oh i knew it
her dad sells sitcoms
oh wow
and there it is baby wanda
oh all the i love lucy bewitched they're
doing movie night
oh
the dick van dyke show and that's why on
[Music]
this
so it's showing wanda and um watching
sitcoms and that's how
that's how that's why everything is in
sitcoms because that's what she grew up
watching as a kid with her family
that scared the crap out of me you can't
just cut to a scene of lightning and
crap
oh her family's home got hit by a
missile oh is this the oh that's just
oh no way they're showing when the stark
missile hit their home
no way
their parents are dead and now their
country is under attack and there's the
stark industry missile
and they just wait for it to explode
there's that red light
that red light from the toaster wow
so she's so wanda had powers
the whole time
she was a witch the whole time what
oh hydra oh
[Music]
wow this is uh
there's now they're going back and
showing where she was experimented on by
hydra dang and guys again i'll say it
again
i talk about spoilers in this live
stream i mean we're watching it live
so agatha is showing her or taking her
through her past
and
oh there's a scary wand of being
experimented on and there's the scepter
what up that's freaky wow that's a witch
wanda maxim off getting experimented on
oof
so she's going to touch the scepter
and oh it appears to her
oh marvel tricked us
oh did marvel really do that oh no they
didn't
interesting
oh that's insane
look who it is
they literally just showed the scarlet
witch
what the heck that's crazy awesome
this is getting intense
wow wow
oh they didn't see it
they didn't see the stone appear to her
they literally showed this scarlet witch
wow
that guy has a theory but she needs
more and now we go through another door
which is going to be
this looks like a hotel room which might
be the hotel room with vision
no oh this is her room in
the avengers tower yep the avengers
compound
she called for a vision and he comes
oh this is the where she was in the
avengers compound
and they first started you know being
together
all right oh and that's where she's
watching
oh
that's where she's watching sitcoms
so
this is where
this is where they start where it all
started
so she's suffering because pedro is dead
and vision doesn't know how to comfort
her
i'm so tired she says
so patreon
so pedro's dead this is after
this after age of ultron and vision is
just trying to comfort her
interesting
huh vision's a little bit more human
than we thought
oh they're bonding they're connecting
and falling in love
and it's beautiful i actually really
like these two i really hope vision
doesn't permanently die
because that's gonna suck and now
wanda is experiencing all of this over
again i kept showing that to her
parents dead brother dead vision dead
oh now we're gonna find out what happens
after avengers in game we're about to
see that avengers in-game post credit
scene where she
sees vision
oh snap here we go oh yeah sword
headquarters
did she really take him like that
footage oh here we go
there she is oh yeah
she's at sword facility she's trying to
find vision
oh she said vision deserves a funeral
and sir
took him she deserves a funeral wow
oh hey words watching her hey words
watching her oh she's about to go ham
through the doors down the hall two
lefts in a
oh she's busted in they let her go
through but
so the letting her go through i wonder
who she's about to i mean it's got to be
hayward right
director and a word
director tyler hayward
he said i'd like to show you something
oh we're they're gonna really see her
take yeah she's like really see him
getting taken apart
oh dang they're tearing apart his body
good
and she is about to be pissed off
oh she's losing it
oh that's so no no no no no he's
oh
we're just
we're dismantling the most sentient
weapon ever
made
he just said not everyone has power like
you do to bring
him back to life
and she said i can't do that i can't
bring people back to life
and he said i can't let you take 3 000
pounds of vibranium something like that
yeah i can't let you take all this
vibranium
she said he's all i have and hayward
said he isn't yours
and now she's about to straight up
attack everybody
yeah she's taking him look at that
you can't stop her hayward said fall
back
hayward do you know that your troops
can't stop them
i mean really
wow she's touching his head oh
oh she said i can't feel you
so was it the mind stone that was him
oh
is she really just leaving
she's straight up just left so
you drive like a normal human you can
fly
there's a there's a letter that's in her
car
now i know there's no way in life when
you're the scarlet witch you're driving
a buick
welcome to new jersey all right we're
about to see what the heck
happened west view wow that's an old
it's like an old town before
look at that and here she comes oh yeah
it's like super old west shoes like
super super old
hey look it's the guy all right so she's
arriving to west view
hey there's norm
hey there's deborah drover up
westview was a sad town wanda did them a
favor
oh west view's a crappy town it's like
all run down
is this where she lives
is this seriously where she lives no
mean it's like a really crappy town
so she's walking around westview
look at this it's a crappy town but
there's an empty lot here
to grow old and what i didn't see what
that said
want to maximize oh that's where they're
supposed to live
oh no they had a house planned and
everything
oh dang
it's the house her envision we're
supposed to live in
oh
she's gonna about to create something
oh
well that's intense
oh she's creating it she's literally
creating it
is happening she just created
everything oh snap
and she so was her
oh step
so is that she created him with the
infinity magic that's inside here
that's when they first came finally we
see this
she crea so she created everything
i know she is interesting
wanda
welcome home
catboy thanks for the super chat i have
not finished the episode yet because it
took me a while to get it online but
thanks for super chat
so i'm still i'm at this part
she's watching everything they turned on
the tv
oh snap it was like they were looking at
cameras the whole entire time
well maybe not and here comes agatha
because it was agatha allah and there's
the
witch
oh snap the kids
oh wow that's intense
and there's the witch
shhh
oh snap
chaos magic
hey they said scarlet witch
wow is there a post credit scene there
is
ready for team is ready for launch
ha interesting
and the weapon that they were creating
spoilers incoming guys big time if you
haven't seen the episode yet
i'm about to show some spoilers because
here
is freaking west coast vision
look at that
oh snap oh snap
holy crap wow that's intense
so okay
this is definitely like an ultron vision
this is definitely like an ultron vision
all right hold on
let's get in the zoom let's get into
zoom meeting
with soups and brad wow
wow wow wow actually i can't get oh
because it's a different email
that's insane
that is insane i can't wow ultron
vision all right that's something
i'm going to call it that and they
finally called her this they finally
said the scarlet witch
wow
matt hutch thank you for the super chat
i think we all know one of the people
paul wanted to work with
was himself oh my gosh can you imagine
dude can you hear me
so someone just said in my chat i don't
want to be pissed
someone was like so the person that paul
bettany really wanted to work with was
himself
can you imagine that you can't do that
to us
like there's no way right like no way
that could be it
i will be so pissed off
i will be so pissed okay so then
it was cool to see everything but kind
of an underwhelming episode
yeah it you know it's really weird how
it was kind of a filler episode
um
there really wasn't um yeah
but no i i thought it was going to be
like big battles and like
stuff going crazy zero action
um
yeah chandler thanks for super chat yo
so the director lied about wanda
stealing vision he did lie
this was kind of like they did another
episode what they did was they did
another episode
where they switched the perspective
right and this perspective
was like completely different
out there perspective sean brower
i need orange slices after this me too
thanks for the
super chat um hey
how's it going um i gotta move this now
um soups i was behind watching it
because the server was down and i think
chris is a little behind watching it
done too
oh that sucks no
dang hi i'm
dang hi i'm dirk thanks for super chat
what do you think of pietro x-men
universe or not
yeah so she said that she
she was him she like created him but why
did it show in that little theme song
that she had her kind of like
controlling him yeah uh
bricks a lot i think super chat yeah
there are two visions now which is kind
of weird but i also wonder
what would happen to the one she created
yo didn't it kind of look like she used
some
like infinity stone magic to create him
you know because like her powers coming
out were all red but when she created
him it was like gold
you know what i mean yeah so like when
when she exploded at the end right
and um and she was creating
the like everything around her um
all the magic coming out of her was red
but when she like got into the living
room inside of her house when she
created vision
that magic was gold so could that
possibly be
from the mine stone right because that's
that color
could that possibly be like energy from
the mind stone that and maybe she
actually did kind of bring it back to
life
yeah stark's weapons did kill her
parents uh juan rosales yeah
and that's uh that's what happened
you keep oh they can't hear you guys
hold on guys
let me get you guys on here they said
they can't hear you and i think i know
why
you guys can hear me i can hear chris
but i can't see chris hey soups how are
you doing man
nice to meet you guys thank you for that
uh brad chris is my
in order best friend roommate editor
nice to meet you brother i revealed this
my camera doesn't want to play along so
you don't get to see my beautiful face
today you're good you're good you're
good
um did you did you select the video
input
yeah it won't connect for whatever
reason like it was earlier
they revealed the x gene in a way by the
way
i agree during the civil war time period
i thought we were going to get a cameo
from hawkeye
yeah we were talking about that before
yeah dude josh campbell thanks for super
chat was a filler
but bigly important information yeah
so so brad and chris i was telling
supes as we got in here i'm going to be
so pissed and somebody said this in my
chat
they were like so the famous actor that
paul bettany always wanted to work with
was
himself that would be hilarious oh my
god frat seems sure
i want to be pissed come on paul don't
do that to me
i would know he i mean
no because they said no because cause
elizabeth olsen confirmed like the luke
skywalker level cam
yeah no i think he's too upstanding of a
guy just in real life even to reference
himself as a fantastic actor he wants to
work with
unless he's trolling us i think
everybody is trolling
dude boys i am oh my gosh
zechariah told us in i think we all were
kind of hoping for a little bit more
i it it still was very important to know
but i think we're all expecting hey the
second to last episode
it's about to hit the fan that's kind of
what i was
look going into this episode i said it
was going to be
agnes heavy yeah i said that yeah
and i said it was gonna be all
flashbacks which is exactly what it was
so this last episode which will probably
be over an hour i would assume with the
time remaining right
yeah it's gonna be just this just not
it's the battle
right now it's gonna happen the next the
episode is gonna i mean and
and that's what they look like for me
it's like
damn man like they just keep dragging it
out and yeah
and out like that's how it feels at this
point
i mean yeah and there were a lot of
flashbacks from that episode but i
definitely think they gave us a lot of
information
just about oh one thousand things that
happened totally no and i
i enjoyed the flashbacks i enjoyed
seeing agatha
i enjoyed all of the flashbacks but it's
just like overall
morgan thank you for the super chat i
can't either i did like the episode even
though it wasn't a lot
max conrad what's up man because i don't
think no worry
put it out there so the part where this
oh i'm so sorry i hope you're feeling
better
mary rose lolly still who is missing
witness
i don't know and i do think the rabbis
is somebody thanks for the super chat
energy there could be
where nico dragon animation
[Music]
yeah i think so and thank you for that
super chat
monica went in right she i i do think
that's
gonna come with the energy christian
avila thank you for the super shot is it
possible that's closer to the subject
there's a lot of
dollars i mean she was too far away at
times i was talking about that i think
so
i think so yeah i feel like i really do
think so i think he's gonna turn it off
okay and is that a mutant's connection
there uh
yeah i mean that's that's i think that's
where they're going with it
for sure um you know to kind of auto
correct
the uh lack of mutants for the first ten
years yeah
yeah gifted route or whatever they yo
what did they call them
the enhanced enhanced enhanced dude
dude at that point like magneto is
dude like that they could definitely
introduce magneto if she had her powers
before the mind stone
she couldn't in his parents stance could
be adopted oh yeah
i think this is the mag yeah dude no
you're right
those prints could be adopted like they
adopted them as
children i actually like that a lot i
think that
because that makes sense because that
literally is like the comic storyline
right i mean it followed it pretty well
so yeah so
so but but i think
so let's talk about how the next episode
is going to go down right because then
you have
vision what who is he going to fight
both the witches wanda and akatha
like right yeah boys and
um man when no sorry to cut you off no
you're good
bro that when we saw that flashback of
her getting her powers and we saw
freaking scarlet witch with them
i know that was so cool
abolish thanks for super chat then of
course we heard scarlet witch this
episode
right and uh uh abolished in my chat
just says i believe the scarlet witch
can defeat agave because agatha looks
scared right calling her the scarlet
witch you're not supposed to exist
she definitely looks scared definitely i
think he looks scared bro
especially after like at the end where
she's just like
she's just ready to like pull on the
down man she's ready to decapitate those
kids is what she's
getting ready to do
yeah agnes really just like
she she she bodied all those witches and
and her flashback
and her mother um i think it would be a
good idea
because right now you know she's in a
funny fourth wall breaking way i think
it would be funny for deadpool to do
that harry ruxman thanks for the super
chat what a vision she created is like
the soul
oh that's a great and and and the white
vision is like merging with them that's
a good idea i like exactly
so much
the white vision is the real vision
someone leave that in their car while a
gamer
thanks for super chat so if that's not
vision how was hayward tracking i'm
always there
uh i'm not sure but i do think that was
vision
mephisto and nightmare jj thanks for the
super chat now we know what everyone has
at stake for the question yeah
and
ultron is back yeah pretty much no
jarvis programming and body ultra
yeah she could have been around here
yeah the finale is going to be insane
thanks for the super chat but it's
definitely interesting matthew king
what's up bro do you think toby could
still be in los angeles
um i think it's less likely now
unfortunately
but i'm hoping what's up
double version oh god about her kind of
like getting
her powers for her 10. because she
couldn't get them yeah
definitely a mutant or witch as they
call her right pirate man thanks for the
super chat why i didn't want to kill
someone like clint if she found out what
an a-hole hayward was up to because
she's acting emotionally
that's why santana
yeah the real django you're true thanks
for super chat this is true i don't even
know man
i don't i don't know bro one at a time
we can't understand you don't know i
just i don't expect them
to yeah that was a great i'm sorry just
trying to post credit addressing the
super chats
uh josh campbell thanks for the super
chat what if she destroyed the minds it
would absorb his essence
i think that's how i think it's true
feeling how we are all feeling i think
it's true
yeah probably
yeah i'm feeling like something's
missing well
a lot a lot i don't think an hour and a
half but the next episode is two hours
so enough time to explain all this no
they won't it's just gonna be
it's just gonna huge cliffhanger yeah
it's into into
doctor strange yeah which is gonna be
great and spiderman
so i still think
well i'll have to rethink my theories
now actually i still think there's a
bigger
villain than her oh for sure for sure
for sure
because like she even in the beginning
she was talking about like
you know this dark power and they had to
like kill her and she killed all them
including her mother and uh you know
she it's just there's something else
there like you know she was working with
dark power before what was she doing she
was you know
and she even mentioned uh necromancy and
all these dark
you know witchcraft stuff like that and
um
there's something else there but now
since there's so
much unanswered i don't think we're
going to get there and
until doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness
yeah yeah i agreed well things that i
don't i don't think they could fit
that much into next episode because next
episode we have to see
action it's all about the kids next
episode exactly
yeah so let's talk about what's going to
happen next episode because
so i'm going to call them ultron vision
because someone mentioned in my chat
like
there is no jarvis wiring in this new
vision
so it's pretty much ultron
and it's going to be at hayward's
command pretty much so uh
dude to be honest when it comes to next
episode
uh first of all at the end there bro i
think wanda has kind of like controlled
like chaos magic now
like it looked like she was
kevin downey what was with the mother
witch at the beginning when a crown
i don't think she was a goddess of
witchcraft i think it was just her mom
and just the head of that
coven at that time that's what i think
i would agree and i think that's i think
that's why they said that i think that's
why they set that up
yeah and agnes directly or agatha
directly said it like
jinxed jay hunks thanks for the super
chat really hoping that those were
adopted parents yeah i'm thinking so too
i'm thinking so too
jordan hey thanks for the super chat
super
she has leverage are they really going
to wrap all this up in one episode i
don't know
there might be a rumor 10 episode i i i
think i'm gonna
i think i'm going to say that so agatha
you marked them wanna using a
probability supposed to keep
yeah nexus beans have the power to
affect probability oh
that's interesting nexus
beans have that i'm gonna take a
screenshot of that so i can see it
the vision was original vision that mark
a vic
the yogi thanks for the super chat the
vision was the original vision that
marvel comics said
yeah yeah it was yeah which is really
cool to see
sean webb hey what's up villain is a
rabbit she even fed him the bug she was
showing up for me hey that's a good
point that's a good point
about the illusions that one has been
creating
so i i don't know man i mean it was so
interesting but when
when wanda lost it at the property which
we saw that in that flashback right yeah
a few weeks ago
um it wasn't just red right
it was that chaos right magic explosion
also the multiverse flickering like
very nexus right so i man i
i can't wait to see what they do with
this now next up tony miller
lights out from start to finish this was
slow tony miller thank you for the super
chat the vision
version represents some of this cold
this is body reflex absence humanity and
more machine
man more machine the man he's no longer
capable of yeah i
i agree i agree
brandon vic boss morgan i'm trying so
i'm trying to
to toggle it all but thank you for that
super chat thanks for letting me know
about that too
pretty cyber thank you for the super
chat we will see the other big chaos
magic user phase four i believe so
i believe so v1b acevodz thanks for the
super chat what happened to wong
i'm not sure about that i think we're
going to find that on doctor strange
multiverse of madness
episodes like i would have preferred
them to have released like
for this i would have preferred last
episode in this episode to have been
combined
and then you have that and then boom
next episode we continue to progress in
the story
yeah rather than go like the falcon in
the winter soldier route
for at least one episode and have it be
longer
instead of having just us wait a week
for like flashbacks
basically and like the story's not
progressed we got zero monica
zero pietro zero vision and we're in the
same spot christian thanks for the super
chat
i i do think there could be something
inside of her
like chatham or something like that yeah
i think so thanks for super chat
hamad s yosof say google want to vision
james spaders and cass
yeah i know but you can't always trust
google
but thank you for that super chat
how how okay
it does and somebody you know just
mentioned in the super chat you know
what about that rumored
tenth episode and i don't know how true
that is
i think it's more not true than true but
i feel like it needs the 10th episode
yeah at this point at this point it
definitely needs a tenth episode
uh ulysses scooter smith for the u
entertainment thank you for that super
chat and
i agree um sh
wanda may be even more powerful
than anybody in the mcu right now and it
is kind of like
jean grey with the phoenix force and
i've mentioned this before i think it's
kind of like
the scarlet witch isn't part of her and
maybe that's like chauthon or something
that we were talking about right
or i did a video on chatham but you know
maybe that's mephisto or somebody else
like that
that's like giving her that power right
because the chaos magic and everything
where does that come from why is she so
different
is it different because she got the
power from the infinity stone
but she had powers before like where
does that come from
yeah i mean i think everybody always
knew that too though i mean you and i
have talked about warren a thousand
times like
and they mention it in the in the
episode like everybody that's come in
contact with the infinity stone died
immediately and
she was different and that's obviously
because of something preset and right
whether it's
from a different being or the mutant
gene or whatever marvel wants to do with
that obviously they have an
endless amount of possibilities i guess
the question is what is marvel trying to
do with that are they
more trying to use wanda to get a big
bad villain like mephisto or
somebody else in or are they trying to
use her to to transition to mutants and
at the end of this
she's going to explode and her power is
going to go across the world and all the
mutants are not going to
have their powers and that's a big
question i i think wanda is shaping up
to be that scarlet witch we saw very
briefly we're going to
check sullivan hope you're doing better
i've been trying to get in
wrapped up right
i'm sorry i was talking they were i
didn't mute them thank you um
and let's let's chat definitely on
instagram um
sorry i've been kind of out of it lately
where is the mindset right now i think
it's done
a vic i i think it's
i think it actually is done
i think it's done the fake vision is
going to combine with the white vision
to become vision again i think so too
slap one face and thank you for that
super chat
matt hutch ultravision is everything
hope believe this could be without the
mindstone
mind vision is what the stone gave him
yeah i agree
that they were talking about that you
know there's a lot more with him
jay london thanks for the super chat who
was the woman floating in yellow
light the hydra i think that was the
scarlet witch like like some weird
manifestation of the scarlet witch
don't don't worry about it don't worry
about it
i always i always tell chris like
because
you know we're just like so tired we do
these right away right when we get off
and we're always i'm always so tired
he's tired
and i'm like yeah i'm gonna try to like
you know not go over every single little
detail and i'm like sending him the
video
okay it's 31 minutes have fun
he makes the breakdowns longer than the
actual show sometimes i do that
there's so much you know no there is a
lot john anderson thanks for that super
chat take it apart
it's fun to sit there for afterwards to
look at it like
you know how marvel is what does this
mean what does this glance mean
right it's always it's always something
with marvel they're so meticulous at
things
thanks for that super chat i want to
take a second to talk about the opening
scene
and and this is the same with such a
great scene it's it's it was a
relationship that we've seen with agnes
yeah and that is that dark tones now
personally i'm a huge horror fan
uh trevza what's up wasn't ultron the
mind stone so wouldn't ultron vision be
a synthesis
without mind stone so not what
ultron was ultron wasn't the mind stone
ultron was really the ai
that tony created the mind stone was
that ultron needed to really control him
and give him power to kind of
to kind of do everything um
that's kind of what what that was
kevin czaro thanks for that donation
super appreciate that guys
it's showing me some super chats and and
not the
and not some so i deeply apologize if
i'm missing
if i'm missing some i really do
for some reason it's only highlighting
some of them so i'm so sorry if i missed
some i
i deeply apologize if i missed some
food blogger's kitchen hey bro i think
hayward knows that she is scarlett which
is why you won
who wants to take her out swim yeah i
agree someone's pulling the strings
for sure which that's why he wants to
take her out yeah i
i agree i agree that's why he wants to
take her out
juan rosales jrp not related to one of
you but have you heard about tom
holland's country ending
yeah but he's not done he also said that
he also said that
if they ask him to come back he would
like i actually just mentioned her i
think he's good i don't know if that's
that's not her goal right now right now
she's trying to figure out why she's so
powerful well she's scared i think
oh she's definitely scared because i
think because as we saw in that opening
scene i
i think she's clearly
like a insanely strong witch so so i
think she's
you know she could kill she killed that
whole coven
there was like nine of them and her mom
who
the crown right someone mentioned my
super chat about the crown i don't think
that's the goddess which
um no that's what i was gonna say i i
don't think so
because then like uh i mean if agatha
killed her
that's what i'm saying like how i mean
how powerful is she gonna
say i could touch them i mean and then
we saw the brooch obviously i don't know
if there's any further meaning other
than it's her mother's obviously we
think like the grim reaper and the two
kids are on it but now it's a little
different than that even
yeah i'm not sure about that now now it
might just be her mom's broach that
well we got a better look at it so i'm
definitely going to see what we can see
zoom in with the yeah let's zoom in
so what can reg vision do without the
stone um
wavy deep production six for super chat
i think he's essentially ultron now
but but he's gonna be like i think he's
like a remote controlled car now
and hayward is controlling him what if
vision's voice is spader oh i think it's
gonna be
oh
oh that would be so cool
but no no no no no it can't be the voice
actor he's talking about because he's
already worked with him in age of ultron
yeah yeah yeah that's not the the cameo
with the actor he was talking about it'd
be cool if he went into west view and he
actually embodied
embodied that like how he turns into
paul benny yeah dude
i thought it was ultron man honestly
yeah me too i mean i think it kind of is
ultron
i mean in a way in a way that's what
jarvis was i mean vision
is right i think it kind of is ultron
that would be cool honestly i'd be hyped
if he talks any sounds like ultron
that'd be
that'd be next level awesome i'll be
fire
so this is a good this is thanks for the
super chat jesse garcia this is a good
thought
says i feel vision will be under control
by sword as
ultron and i think it's like
transformers when they rebuilt megatron
and he later showed that he was actually
controlled
and not the humans and maybe that's
something that this white vision slash
ultron
will kind of do and i think that would
be actually pretty cool like the sword
thinks they control him but
it's like psych yeah right and then now
you have like another problem to deal
with
that could happen
if white vision was vision why did he
look at his hand all confused
jonathan sanchez i don't because i think
it i think it's not vision i think it's
like
part ultron bro without jarvis
boys what happened marvel marvel india
tweeted on twitter
two episodes left oh there we go okay
good
two episodes conference about time two
episodes
jeez all right ten episodes ten episodes
thank you oh you know what i you know
what
i wonder if they saw tweets and crap and
people were like what the hell and
they're like oh my gosh somebody just
tweet that there's two episodes left
like
calm everybody down there's tenth
episode that's
epic okay guys guys guys let's let's
let's chill before everybody [ __ ]
loses their [ __ ] i i saw the tweet from
marvel uk but that's a bold [ __ ]
statement
somebody's either getting fired or uh
we're
lucked out
hmm i'm checking twitter man tim wonder
i'm gonna have to check back on that
um that's kind of fuzzy right now but
you could be right i don't think we're
gonna
be right i'm looking for that i'm coming
right now give me a second yeah let's
let's take a look into this
a vik niyogi eternity versus infinity
affinity
so much hype so much defeated to create
the six stones the big bang so eternity
going to time to internals involvements
here
yeah i think it could i think it could
for sure
kevin sarro thanks for the super chat at
37 there's something glowing do you
think it's important anyway oh i
actually saw that i marked the time
um i'm not sure i'm gonna have to dive
into that but thank you for that super
chat
jay rollins i think we're gonna end up
the cliffhanger i really hope not man
but i think so i think they're coming in
multiverse of madness sadly
i i think that's happening andrew ross
when the kids are getting choked one is
ready match looked very different
had black in it very bad yeah i i think
it could be that chaos magic is what i'm
talk is what i'm thinking
there's emotional scenes where
quintessential for one of those asian
development
oh no i totally agree i totally agree
totally totally agree
it's a 100 necessary necessary
uh uh episode and just because i want
more
once i just because i wanted more action
doesn't mean it was bad bunny and means
i don't think it was bad upset at all
and i think 100 wasn't necessary that
they they had to show everything
they had to
was it the actual marvel uk account yeah
yeah yeah but the way it was worded it's
starting to seem not like it
like that's not what it meant brah well
yeah because it's like
technically i guess you know including
this one i guess
including this one because including
this one yeah yeah
i i i tweeted someone and and they
basically said
as much it's still nine dang it i don't
think
i don't think the ninth is gonna be
longer than an hour no i don't think it
is either because
uh matt schaefer said it was all
together like six hours and
and i did the math like this week at
some point in time i was like well yeah
this leaves like an hour maybe hour 15
for the final episode
i think we just need to expect a
a huge cliffhanger and just be happy
with that i guess like that's the only
way we're walking out of that one i
i hope i do think we're gonna get a
cliffhanger guys
i am i'm sorry to say
[Music]
well there was a leak that said that
like one of the kids is gone but one of
the kids is in
well i think we're done
yeah billy billy no tommy tommy
tommy oh that's an interesting one
thanks for the super chat
damon madement ultra oh ultron vision
will turn into wonder man
that actually would be cool that
actually makes sense
if somebody says hayward is a skrull
yeah brandon shannon think of super chat
i know he i know james spader is
credited as a voice
yeah what the heck you can't trust
google sometimes that's all
i hate that guy more and more every
episode
hey thanks sean for the super chat okay
we're talking like a great
trip without the singing brad thoughts
on the buddy still bro
did you match a commercial yeah brad
she was talking to the bunny brad bro
he's talking to the bunny
you think it's uh nicholas here's my
thing on nicholas
mark daniel thanks for the super chat i
it did kind of feel like that your magic
commercial
i i agree with you ninth and final
episode chris younover thanks for the
super chat i appreciate that
phase 12. sean thanks for super chat
i'm sorry just trying to make sure that
you guys yeah i know they tweeted
gms 2005 thanks for super chat
disney plus uk tweeted their two
episodes left yeah but i think
that they're talking about this episode
and the ninth episode
i think that's the problem umama sarwat
thanks for the super chat i appreciate
that
and i apologize if i missed any super
chats guys i'm really really trying it's
only highlighting some for some reason
on my
on my uh on my chat so i i deeply
apologize if i'm missing some
i said look well when wanda sat down on
the couch
last episode she looked at the bunny and
and there was some like static noise
like the bunny was trying to communicate
what kind of looked at it like what the
heck
right yeah for sure and and the fact
that she was talking to it this episode
really does kind of like
it's it's not like because she like
demonstrated with like the fly
or the whatever that thing was she kind
of demonstrated like oh yeah i can do
all this stuff and i'm controlling it
right
and it's literally like a fly on the
wall how she's like kind of
like listening in on some things and
that's what she kind of used to listen
some things but
she didn't manipulate the rabbit at all
and
i do think it's i think it's somebody
i definitely think it's somebody i'm
very curious to see who it is but
i said on the stream earlier like
strange is either in a
like a broom cupboard
but like that that's the thing going
into this final episode like we know
there's going to be cameos
but it's like okay we're getting the
aerospace engineer cameo because
yeah tiana paris again hyped it up so
much
yeah we haven't seen it yet
what hey let let's just not
jump the gun here okay y'all just dude
i'm coming up i'm coming off a list she
said homie yeah what she said
that's what she said chris hassan the
woman
see one day that could be
that could be the lucas baby that'd be
cool he's
on the screen with himself i mean sean
webb thank you so much funny is the main
villain
go back and watch feeds represents
evolving i'm telling you
maybe sean i hope so i hope it's
somebody i
i really do hope it's somebody thomas
henderson at this point i do think
vision survives
paul said a couple times that he doesn't
want to say more because he doesn't want
to be fired fired from what yeah you're
right thomas
and thanks for the super chat appreciate
that
one shot feel like cassidy m appears was
a waste with the revelations episode
should have just gotten aaron maybe
yeah you're right one shot i appreciate
the super chat
pete afado i got the said fake pietro
well petro i think it's quicksilver from
fox
um i don't know i think she might have
just created him
but she did mention about bringing you
know the dead body
so maybe i think it might be him yeah
so basically all the leaks and spoilers
were wrong for this episode pretty much
chris and thanks for the super
super chat
rain nantowski danny devito should
oh my gosh that would be great i would
love it so much
michael jasper we tried every power
source under the sun
reference to the solar jewel
ah i want to say yes but i don't think
so but that's a great thought
it's a really great thought do that in
one in an episode because
they're they're reading this like a
movie here are all the things we're
gonna build you up with
and then let's slowly over the next
episodes the next movies
give that to you that's my opinion on
that
yeah it's hard we don't know the
the grand picture so you know it's hard
for me to say
like i don't agree with this right
because i don't know how it's going to
end
but i would say that i don't like the
idea
of them just doing a series
to build up a movie
you know
look the thing is that all of their
projects have been
movies that also set up over other
movies but they're their own thing
right exactly that's what i'm saying so
i don't i don't like i want this
like i want this to have its own ending
i want it to be a satisfying end right
and then also set up multiverse of
madness right not that word just
ends and like the like just like
it just ends super abruptly like
everywhere
i'm gonna be very mad if they do that
that's what i'm saying like
i don't want them to treat this as a
build-up to a movie i want it to be its
own
its own thing have its own ending like
you just said
zach lloyd thanks for the super chat
what do we think about the missing
witness i
it's so weird at this point it's like is
it somebody is it not somebody
guys what do we think there's so many
things that just dude and then it's like
and then there's the bunny there's ralph
the bunny ralph
dottie is she another witch you know a
bunch of stuff
i mean it's super possible she didn't
even have a husband and she was just
referencing one like she was saying like
she's not weird for not having one right
yeah
oh and there's so many there's so many
ways that all this stuff could be
explained simply and we always jump to
like the super con we do
yeah here's here's a uh sarah moana
thanks for super chat here's a
question that i that i actually asked
how did hayward track a vision and the
hex then
because he's like they were tracking
vision but they have their own vision
like that's made from his body so
he was tracking his energy or
that's a question i actually i actually
was wondering about that myself
when when i saw it pop up it's like how
is he tracking vision then
not sure damon madement every place
agathon wanted to go
their commercial oh yeah kind of yeah a
few of those were kind of yeah
oh wait i didn't pay close enough
attention oh no it wasn't because you
know how a lot of people were saying
that the commerce the people in the
commercial were actually going to be
like yeah
they weren't yeah they weren't yeah i
don't know what the future is for agatha
but i hope she has
a lot of relevance i hope she doesn't
get killed
i hope she doesn't really kill him
thanks for the super jack casey
i think she's going to get obliterated i
know i know she is but
that's why i that's why i said i hope
she doesn't get killed because i feel
that too soups that's why i said i hope
not but i
i really feel it from the beginning of
the episode when she's standing there
and she's like
i didn't do any of this and it's like
she's like so believable
and then the whole thing flips and turns
it's like i didn't break any rules
they just bent to my power like yeah
that was a good line it's like
this character is insane i would not be
surprised if we see her and
versus madness i hope we do i still
think i've been
i did a few videos over the past couple
weeks about this i still think with the
dark cold
there's nightmare mephisto chathan
something
in another plane that can't get to the
earth plane and she needs
a way to get him there and i thought
that
maybe shaythan marked wanda like he did
in the comics that's where her chaos
magic came from
and that's how he's gonna return and
maybe maybe that's true because you know
agave is saying like you're not supposed
to exist like how do you how do you
exist how is this possible
well maybe maybe she is marked by
chatham
i think if that's the case and i'm
talking about mephisto nightmare
jathon think of one name it i do not
think we get to see them this episode no
no we don't see them in the series
superman we don't see them till dr
strange
there might be a reference or a shadow
but we will not see or have an answer
till dr strange yeah yeah
a ton of people in my chat are saying um
spaders and the wannabe
cast list but guys we can't google yeah
they're not legit no the same way you uh
sean
i don't know thank you for the super
chat sean brauer i don't know i don't
kevin feige said he doesn't want to say
no to the second season but the second
season he kind of said was
dr strange mulder versus madness
hayward's track and a secret project was
a ruse to buy him time to get a sample
of her power
he allowed darcy to hack the info that's
a good call
i agree with that shayna the gray thanks
for the super chat
so there's so much information but yeah
that's funny
yeah so much information a lot of
satisfying short answers
such a great performance though like oh
totally totally i think she was great
she was great she was great
i think that was lizzie's best
performance md's mdc
mdcz thanks for the super chat maybe he
trapped the energy source but they said
he was tracking
vision himself read bowens thanks for
the super chat they track vision and the
hex because
uh but i don't think the but the vision
created in the hex i don't think is
the vision with vibranium is my thing
prometheus thanks for super chat thanos
i'll do it myself cliffhanger
i hope not sean webb thanks for the
super shock eric moore thanks for the
super chat
jordan hancock would want to first saw
visions mutilated bodies started putting
energy in the head
thought she's going to wake up and just
start screaming that'd be crazy
there's a lot of cool things about what
we saw
brick boy gaming thanks for super chat
please explain earlier in the show hey
where she has wanted to tr
tragic vision but now she creates him in
the house and she builds and what's
going on
i think he was lying i think somebody
just explained it i think she was lying
sean webb they cannot track the
vibranium because it's fake vision made
by wanna just
yeah so the the vision inside
is the vision inside doesn't have
vibranium body
christian over thanks for super chat i
didn't see one spoiler that predicted
this episode
or was even come close to this episode
yeah you could probably conclude they
were good guesses
i don't think i think he was lying
because the vision inside the hex
doesn't have
vibranium but that's a good thought corn
i'll have to look back into that thanks
for super chat
brian salgado zach of actually putting
her through this flashback to get her to
come out of darkness
maybe just assume you give her yeah
maybe
i think she's going to teach her spells
something i don't get why does agnes
want to know so much on how she turned
i don't know i think agnes might end up
teaching her at the end
is that actually putting her through i'm
sorry i just said that jonathan sanchez
thanks again but what if want to just
create anything she always bring him too
i mean that's possible yeah
hassan hinks if sword was able to
activate white vision with juana's magic
then how was unable
how was unable to do it herself at the
base i don't think
sword used wanda's magic to do it i
think it's like old tron
x-axis wait everyone's missed the bigger
picture she had her powers before the
zone yeah no she did yeah it's crazy
and we talked about that comes on the
screen when wanda was like touching the
mind stone
and like loki i was getting triggered
for no reason
my blood was boiling uh soup says ptsd
we're all we're all gonna have feeds so
quick
they yeah they do and this one was
longer and it
seemed like it went but yeah it seemed
like it went by like the quickest of
them
actually because i was i was like super
invested in everything i was being shown
right same i'm not like i'm not saying
like they shouldn't have shown us all
this because i think it's definitely
important to the plot and understanding
everything
but you know i mean really
i don't think one episode is enough to
or or i guess just
it's really not going to end how we
thought it would end yeah
everybody in my chat just said nick fury
is rounding up an army of skull
skulls to do something scrolls sorry to
do something i mean yeah that could be
a connection to um battle world
eventually but
yeah i mean nick fury isn't done right
he's not about to retire so
the main thing is for me the main thing
is i don't think
as many people we thought were going to
be involved with the show aren't going
to be involved in the show
like at this point dude i'm even
doubting strangers cameo honestly
i feel comfortable strange i feel pretty
confident
honestly i'm gonna decide more on sweeps
aside really
oh we have a 50 50 split yeah i think i
think
i'm doubting everything now well because
what if what if the rabbit is doctor
strange and
she just says strange you know like
simple answers guys
no i don't think anybody's capturing
doctor strange anytime soon he's still
pretty powerful
bluey 2010 x-men multiverse for one
division is dead
yeah i don't know about the whole what
did she what did she call him fake true
like fake pietro fiat that was pretty
clever
um vulgar language
thanks for the super chat do i believe
the leaks about ego the seventh infinity
stone
uh no no the last time i heard anything
about that was like
when i theorized that maybe that the
seventh infinity stone could pop up in
end game
md cz thanks to super chat scarlet witch
appeared when wanda needs help
well she she like is the scarlet witch
and i still think yeah right i i i do
think it's like a phoenix force
type of thing yeah it's like a separate
entity
but it is her and in this case i
actually think it it's like a good
entity
i don't think it's like you know phoenix
forces kind of
bad i i think it's a good entity
yo but one thing i i i'm pretty
confident i guess it's like the only
confident thing i think we'll see next
episode
especially with the way it ended with
like agnes holding the kids like hostage
dude i think we'll see like an
incredibles style like fight
yeah that'd be really cool i would uh i
would really like to see that
like i wouldn't be surprised like
if vision just flies in and like knocks
agatha and then like
the the kids are out of her control
all right thanks for super chat white
vision can be made from adamantium well
i think the white vision is still made
out of vibranium
tim wonder two things one to stop the
bomb in scovia yep
two they're setting up agnes as the
person who has to stop wanda
yeah they kind of are aren't they thanks
for that super chat
who knows who's stronger at this point
right nicked a dancer they should have
at least revealed to us ultron vision
voice actor i know
right that'd be so cool to add to hype
thanks for the super chat
okay of faith thank you so much for that
super chat i really appreciate it
alexander adraki when wanda was
recreating vision there was yellow
energy instead of one i know i saw that
uh i don't know if it's goddess of
witchcraft i think it might be more of
like the infinity stone
magic but you could be onto something
there
like i don't think it's going to wrap up
any time like i think weird
that's a big screw you though like i
hate that
guys we have no baseline for these
marvel
and yeah we're in the new territory so
we we can't compare them to the films
because they're not
this is the tv show and what we've
gotten so far
is phenomenal yeah it's all it's truly
been
so we we
but what what what is the landing maybe
the landing's in
multiverse and madness yeah like who
where people like shots okay but like
infinity war
wasn't you know infinity war was like
the build up to end game but like
infinity war was still its own thing and
it had such a satisfying ending
even though it led into was it really
satisfying to say i i didn't know
the theater i was satisfied i'm not
gonna lie i decided with soups again
i think it stands on its own after the
fact and
everybody walking out of there was like
what the [ __ ] just i walked out with
shaking and very i mean we walk out of
that after every marvel movie
i but i visited that was a very special
i thought it was cool though because i
was like they don't ever do that like
they didn't win like when do you see
that right like
i thought it was really cool i loved it
end game was satisfying minus you know
my boy eating [ __ ] but whatever
we're not going to talk about that no
and that's the thing you know we're not
what happened before we're in phase one
like the infinity stock is over we're
starting over we're back at
what happened to monica and it's
something new like she didn't see wanda
outside yeah i don't i
i i don't know she she had she was under
control
of akatha i guess or the fake patriot
what if the scarlet witch is a witch
prophecy
matt hutch thanks for don't know that's
not a bad idea
no not a bad theory
i think wanda saw agnes mom she had a
glory crown the same way her mom did jay
rollins thanks for the super chat i'll
have to check that out
i did notice that but i do think it's
like a manifestation of the scarlet
witch
is kind of what i think it is i think
it's like a separate entity that's like
inside of her
but is also like a good entity
i agree we jump [ __ ] that's all i'm
saying well
it's it's a hard situation especially
since we've had to wait so long because
of covid
yeah and we want the market we want
everything right
i'm ready for however this ends i'm
ready for the next endgame level event
but we're
we're years away from that so and i do
wonder
and i don't think the answer is very
much but i wonder how much black widow
being moved around
falcon and the winter soldier being
moved around has affected
what they had released i don't think
they don't think anything i don't think
project is really
late at all no i don't think i wonder if
it does somehow make a difference
yeah no i don't think it makes a huge
difference because it's like separate
storylines no completely different
oh that's a good point thanks for super
chat alex shows vlogs this explains
why vision has some of wanda's memories
because she like created him but at the
same time he doesn't you know remember
like what happened outside tony miller
thinks super chat who's missing person
you know i
i hate to tell you this i don't know if
it's going to be revealed i don't know
if it's somebody or nobody
you know i really i
don't want to be left on a on like a
huge cliffhanger if it's a cliffhanger i
would rather be an infinity
war cliffhanger i've seen warren make
his way to the edge of a 200 000
million feet high cliff he has yes he is
it's it's a great site but i don't think
he wants it's not a it's not a great
site
i i literally crawled like chris and our
friend walked right up to the edge and
sat down i
like was 40 foot back crawling to the
edge because i was terrified
so point is warren hates cliffhangers i
hate gloving
well guys we have a lot to dissect yeah
a lot of boys i'm gonna wrap it up yeah
that was good to me man
thanks for letting me enjoy your pal wow
guys but thank you guys for tuning into
the live stream
appreciate you guys again we're gonna be
back over here next week for
one mission episode nine the season
finale
so finale next week again it all goes
down next week
that's when it all goes down so yeah
we look forward to seeing you guys next
week appreciate you guys again make sure
to go check out brad warren
chris check out everyone's content shout
out to everyone for
joining us for these watch parties and
we look forward to seeing you next week
peace peace take care guys guys was
awesome
next week for the finale we'll see what
happens
take care guys you guys are awesome see
ya
peace boys all right
well
let me address some super chats real
quick and guys i just got to say again
i am so sorry if i missed any super
chats i really try to hit them all
um i think i just realized it only tells
me about it only like
notifies me if i have a super chat over
five dollars i think that's been like
the trend here
so i'm sorry
peter is 100 not signed on for a short
roll
he will be possessed by chatham on the
end hamill's nightmare maybe it would be
a luke skyward cameo
doug i'm with you on that one entirely
because i don't have caught my video
that i did
not too long ago um i think chathan
has marked wanda i think i think that's
how she gets her chaos magic
i think there is a bigger villain than
agatha and it's clear that she was
harnessing some type of dark power
you know however many thousands of years
ago
that was so i'm with you on that one i
thank you for that super chat
let me see i know i miss some i don't
want to miss them
honey graham i'm still guessing wanna
becomes the big bad and that's the
cliffhanger i think she will lose her
children and break fully
that's the last episode i think you have
a pretty decent chance of being right
about that
and that's what i thought in the very
beginning one is gonna have a mental
breakdown and shatter realities and
that's gonna
kind of be all combined to another yeah
i'm with you on that one
i'm with you on that one well guys uh
i'm gonna do the breakdown it is very
late
um i appreciate everybody stopping by
i appreciate all the support it was a
great great great
uh live stream today it was a great
episode
wasn't what we expected but it was still
a great episode to me we needed to see
all this stuff
and it was cool to see and it explained
a lot but we still have some questions
and i hope i hope they get answered
jack buckley thank you so much for the
super chat guys there is a little bit of
a delay
um and i am about to get off so i
wouldn't do any more super chats because
i
don't want you to waste them for me not
to see them because i i deeply
appreciate them all
but i'm about to get off here um so
don't don't waste money uh but seriously
i appreciate everybody so much
my surgery is it was
it was nice to see how the community
actually felt because sometimes i think
you know people don't really care about
me they care about the content which i
like completely understand that's why i
don't really put my face
in my videos and stuff like that because
i'm just like people don't care people
just want the content
so it's nice to hear from you all and i
super super appreciate that
all the kind words thoughts and prayers
manolo
lick you see how agatha wants the level
of magic that wanda has but in order for
her to get to that level she needs an
infinity stone just like wanda
but the infinity stones longer exist in
this universe good point
because she did realize that and she did
say she's not supposed to exist though i
still i think there's another different
type of
i think there's another element and i
think it's like chathan that that's what
i think
i don't think mephisto or nightmare
involved anymore guys to be perfectly
honest
i think it's jathon more than anything
so
but all right guys i'm gonna get started
on my breakdown gotta watch this thing
again and it was a long one
i'm gonna break down all the easter eggs
i can possibly figure out gonna of
course give you a theory about what i
think is going to happen and i
just i just hope we don't get left on a
cliffhanger
next episode because that's really not
what i want
so hey you guys are awesome thank you so
much for joining me tonight
thank you so much for the kind of words
that you guys gave me about my surgery
i'm recovering well
um look out for my breakdown probably
three four hours something like that um
depending on how long i dive into this
and like what i find obviously so
uh we'll see but thank you so much for
joining me guys i'll see you guys next
time
next week the finale sadly
hopefully it's like an hour and a half
long so
oh thank you suresh i care for you all
too you guys are awesome
um but the finale hopefully it's like an
hour and a half
next week hopefully they they really
hopefully it's really satisfying and i
trust marvel
so i feel good so but next week
same time one division finale